اعترف الجيش الاسرائيلي بمقتل جنديين في
المعارك بشمال قطاع غزه الليله الماضيه
وكانت تل ابيب اعلنت مقتل ضابط بسلاح
المدرعات وجندي من وحده الهندسه امس الاحد
ليصل عدد من لقوا مصرعهم الى 17 عسكريا
وضابطا خلال يومين وبهذا يرتفع المجمل منذ
عمليه طوفان الاقصى والحرب على غزه الى
489 بينهم 162 قتلوا منذ بدء العمليه
البريه ونقلت وحده الانقاذ الجويه التابعه
لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي عددا من الجنود
الجرحى خلال المعارك المحتدم في مخيم
جباليه شمالي قطاع غزا شهدت المروحيه وهي
تحط في منطقه غلاف غزه ثم تنطلق صوب احد
المستشفيات داخل اسرائيل وكان فريق
الجزيره قد رصد معارك ضاريه دارت رحاها في
مخيم جباليا حيث تعرض المخيم لغارات جويه
مكثفه وقصف مدفعي شديد من جانب اخر قالت
القناه الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه ان الجيش
وصف نهايه الاسبوع الماضي بانها الاقصى
منذ بدايه الحرب بعد مقتل
14 من
جنوده في الخبر العاجل على على شاشتنا
نقلا عن سفير اسرائيل بواشنطن الذي يقول
انه من مصلحه اسرائيل التوصل الى اتفاق
لاطلاق سراح الرهائن في غزه اما في باقي
المتابعات فنرصد
تفاصيل هذا المشهد في اسرائيل بعد ارتفاع
حصيله القتلى في صفوف الجنود والضباط
الاسرائيليين مع مدير مكتبنا من رام الله
وليد العمري وليد ماذا عن باقي ردود الفعل
والمتابعات بعد ارتفاع هذه الحصيله الى ما
يقرب ال 500 جندي وضابط اسرائيلي قتلوا
منذ عمليه طوفان
الاقصى بالاعلان عن مقتل جنديين في معارك
في شمال قطاع غزه يكون قد ارتفع عدد
الجنود والضباط الاسرائيليين الذين قتلوا
خلال اليومين الماضيين الى 17 قتيلا من
الجنود والضباط في الشمال وفي الوسط وفي
الجنوب ولذلك وصف الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه
الايام او نهايه الاسبوع كما اطلق عليها
بانها الاقسى منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه في
اشاره الى ان المعارك كانت ضاريه جدا وما
تزال وانه يواجه في الشمال حرب عصابات حيث
يشن مقاتلون من خلايا صغيره اثنين او شخص
بمفرده هجمات على قواته ويوقعون فيها
خسائر وهناك ايضا المعارك الضاريه الضروس
التي تجري سواء في منطقه منطقه وسط قطاع
غزه او ما تسمى بمحافظه الوسطى في قطاع
غزه حيث هناك ثلاثه من مخيمات اللاجئين
البريج والمغازي والنصيرات حول مدينه دير
البلح والاهم هي منطقه خانيونس هذه
المنطقه يقول بانه يواجه فيها قتالا ضاريا
فوق الارض وتحت الارض وان قواته تحقق
تقدما لكن القتال شرس وكان قد عزز من
قواته خلال الايام الماضيه باربعه كتائبه
جديده خاصه من قوات الهندسه والمظليين
لذلك يعتقدوا بان هذه المنطقه خان يونس
تحديدا في جنوبي القطاع هي المنطقه التي
تتواجد فيها قياده كتائب القسام وحركه
حماس وهو يريد الوصول اليهم حسب ما يردد
هذا الوضع في مجمله ينعكس على الشارع
الاسرائيلي بتاثير كبير خاصه وان اعداد
القتلى ازدادت بشكل لافت في الايام
الاخيره وارتفعت الى 17 قتيلا بالاضافه
الى نحو 44 من الجنود والضباط الذين
اصيبوا بجراح في هذه المعارك ونقلوا الى
مستشفيات داخل اسرائيل من خلال وحده
الاسعاف العسكريه المعروفه 669 التي
تستخدم المروحيات بكثافه لنقل المصابين
هذا الوضع في مجمله كما قلت يؤثر على
الشارع الاسرائيلي لذلك بدا الحديث يتزايد
عن احتمال ان تبدا فعلا مفاوضات جديه من
اجل الوصول الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى ووقف
لاطلاق النار مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
سيجتمع هذه الليله لبحث المنحى المصري كما
يسمونه القائم على ثلاثه مراحل من اجل
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار لكن كافه
الجهود المبذوله سواء مع الوسطاء المصريين
والقطريين والولايات المتحده بين اسرائيل
وحماس وصلت الى طريق مسدود حسب ما يتردد
ويتسرب من المصادر الاسرائيليه والموقف في
اسرائيل منقسم على ذاته فهناك موقف يرفض
وقف اطلاق النار وموقف اخر يقول يجب وقف
اطلاق النار وابرام صفقه تبادل شامله
لانهاء هذه الاوضاع بكاملها شكرا لك وليد
العمري مدير مكتبنا كنت معنا من رام الله